oh
oh wow
wow
by now everyone's seen that moment from
the 2022 oscars
that was a
greatest night in the history of
television will smith slapping chris
rock across the face after the comedian
made this joke about the king richard
starr's wife jada pinkett smith jada i
love you g.i jane 2 can't wait to see it
all right
now a source tells e.t how chris is
coping revealing it's been an emotional
week as chris returns to work on his
comedy tour
[Applause]
et source explains that while the
saturday night live alum is used to fame
he's never experienced it like this
before adding that there was a mob of
photographers chasing him from his hotel
to the theater in boston where he
performed on wednesday night quote there
were even choppers following him
about what happened
[Applause]
chris performed two shows to sold out
crowds speaking out for the first time
about the surprise smackdown this is a
once-in-a-lifetime experience
yolo i've always thought he was
hilarious i didn't even know he was
going to be in boston until i googled
the incident and got some ads for it
and then i'm dying to know what he has
to say about what happened with will
smith chris got emotional after he was
greeted with not one but two standing
ovations from his audience
you see stars like them they seem like
they're on another level and sometimes
we feel a little detached from good
seeing that human
you know reaction and feeling that love
from boston that is like look we love
you and we appreciated you being here
and we're with you and he felt it and it
felt great
and while chris didn't go into all the
juicy details about the oscar incident
[Applause]
e.t source says chris has beefed up his
security and is really taking this time
to wrap his head around everything that
happened
[Laughter]
and while the star continues to process
it all one thing's for sure he still
knows how to bring the funny
it's funny
you need to be funny he was funny my
eyes were crying
i was loving it everything he talked
about was hilarious he did a set it was
enjoyable i'd say it totally lived up to
it i mean he's just the kind of guy that
his aura and um you know whether he's
got you know even if he didn't have
jokes planned which obviously he did
just his energy and being there is so
something i really wanted to see so
that's why i got tickets and i'm so glad
[Music]
you